the Uncharted story isn't quite done and  the lost legacy will tell another  chapter in 2017 the standalone dlc star  supporting characters Chloe and Nadine  and it'll be set in India in an  interview with official PlayStation  Magazine game director Kurt Marga no  talked about what this means for the  tone and gameplay of the new chapter he  said I would say we're going a little  more why this time I don't want to give  too much away but it's something we're  excited about on the gameplay side this  kind of contrast of an urban setting and  a rural setting a tighter experience and  more open experience uncharted the Lost  Legacy is coming to ps4 at some point in  2017 marcano added that it was  originally meant to be an expansion but  the team instead elected to make it a  standalone game keep an eye on gamespot  for more info as it trickles out and for  all the biggest uncharted news be sure  to hit that subscribe button